I want to see if you can remember this
next bit Part C says calculate the
variance of this distribution we needed
the expected value to calculate variance
can someone remind me if I want to work
out the variance of this distribution
I'm gonna add up more things what am I
going to add up so if you own anything
hold on hold on yeah all right all right
so we know it so let's let's all get
together right let's see we're in hopes
of yet we start with we're going to add
up each particular value we want to find
the difference between this and the and
what do we just work out it's not the
medium it's the expected value which is
very in this case is identical but we
write that as a that's a capital X sorry
like so okay why am i subtracting why
subtracting not different I'm finding a
difference yes sir what's the difference
between ten and seven you do ten take
away seven yeah okay so I do that do I
just leave it what do i square very good
all I want to know is how far away do
these scores vary how far so therefore
I'm not interested in positives or
negatives I just want a positive one
last thing what I multiply by same as
before the same as before it's the
probability of each of those different
things okay so I'm gonna write P of X
and just like before I'm gonna start at
zero and I'm gonna go to the what was a
bit cheeky before no one caught me I
don't actually got to four I don't go up
to four I actually go up two cannot how
many there are
look at the number of bar graphs right
there it goes
two three four five so how many values
have I got one two three four of them so
if I actually counted from zero
I'd go zero one two three would actually
be the last one that was a bit sneaky
I'll put it in a different color to
highlight it okay so same thing here
all right now oh yeah okay all right all
right so I did I did gloss over that
right so what are we talking about when
we write x with an eye underneath can I
ask you guys to think back to Cornett
geometry think way back to cornet
geometry okay it's like this is a while
ago right like save the midpoint of two
points do you remember that you want to
calculate the midpoint between two
things
what was the UM what was the formula I
remember had some X's and Y's in it
that's my clue to you okay he had an x
one very good plus well before I get the
rule that's a bad plus no I'm still in
the x value over here it's x2 very good
and then I divide by two then what I do
for my Y values y1 plus y2 and then I
also divided by 2
okay now think about this right in this
context the x1 x2 all they mean is a
first value and a second value they
don't tell you anything about what those
values actually are that could be like
negative 8 and that could be like pi
doesn't matter what the numbers are this
just means the first one and the second
one okay it's the same deal here what
I'm doing is I'm saying he's the zeroeth
value and then he's the one
I'm not saying first because it's not
actually then that one and then that one
okay now in this particular example
what's the first number that you saw on
the horizontal axis mmm the first one
that we actually had a bar on just to
wasn't that it was two and then what was
the next one three and four and five so
when I'm writing this what I'm saying is
hey add up these X values I'm just
labeling them like this okay and then
when I go to this next part I say what
the actual values are are two three four
five just like you told me
okay does that make sense if I start
from zero if I want four values I count
0 1 2 3 that gives me 4 is that ok it's
a bit weird don't worry too much about
it I just noticed that I wrote it wrong
so want to fix it okay do you want me to
write you the first part of this line or
do you guys reckon you can start it on
your own hands up if you reckon you
could start on your own ends up all
right
that's enough for me
you cannot call me ever and I'll help
you out I'll give you maybe a couple of
minutes to get a head start on it and
then I'll show you what mine looks like
boy this is what we just have a look at
this is that table that you guys helped
me create here is me calculating the
variance okay so I just find that there
are less brackets and less symbols
floating around if I actually write the
probability at the front like we can
change the order of multiplication do
you agree like it doesn't matter whether
you write at first or second I write the
probability at the front and then here's
my difference and then I square it okay
probability difference square
probability and so on okay you do get
one that's very nice okay when you do
this standard deviation this is
something a lot of you I've seen you
just kind of go straight to the answer
please actually tell me what you're
doing but it's it seems immaterial you
like the square root of ones one dude I
don't need to write that do I I want to
see as a marker that you know how to get
standard deviation from variance most of
the time it won't be equal to just one
so actually put that step in there
please don't skip it doesn't take you
long anyway okay what happens right like
numbers your numbers went wrong yeah do
you mean like what was your variance
that you calculated be care for one of
the problems with this is just punching
too many buttons into your calculator
it's really easy to just do a minus sign
or double tap a button than usual okay
now guys I just want to show you this
quickly I'm not even going to walk you
through I think you guys can understand
what's written there it says would you
expect the standard deviation to be
greater than less than or equal for this
distribution compared to the original
one right now I wonder if when you
looked at this new graph you're like
this looks just like the other graph
right what's the difference by the way
there is a difference what's the
difference
very good it's going the other way do
you guys remember I'm scratching around
here do you remember when we used to
talk about skew do you remember that
word pot positive and negative is good
this one here is positively skewed it's
where the tail is going okay the tails
going this way it's positively skewed
the one we started with was negatively
skewed but otherwise look at the shape
they're identical right do you agree
with that just backwards so that's why
you can see I've written given the shape
and the values are the same they're all
2 3 4 5 etc they should be identical but
then you just you can do the calculation
and you'll find exactly the same thing
same expected value sorry different
expected value but the same variance and
therefore the same standard deviation
said ok one quick thing why is the
expected value different even though the
standard deviation is the same I mean I
lost it again
why is the standard deviation and the
various they're the same but the
expected value is 2 completely different
wife very good yeah it's more values
that are lower this is 3 whereas the
previous expected value guys calculated
was 4 because you're more towards the
high end of town does that make sense